uh the jays would love to get to
tomorrow
the rays would obviously love to clinch
it tyler glass now
if he's getting uncle charlie over in
those first 15 pitches this is going to
be a short series for the jays
vgo three straight fastballs
three straight strikes 99 at the knees
that ball just planes out i mean when a
guy is that tall and he's throwing it
down towards your knees
you swear it's going to hit the ground
and then it just catches that plane and
sticks and that character's glove and
there's nothing you can do
beau buchet goes after the first pitch
in the air kiermeyer catches everything
out there
and he's got that one here's lourdes
gurille jr
coryell center field kumar back
and has it and tyler glass now
on seven pitches sails through the first
crosso in the box
rosso lines it into left field and
that's a base hit gorilla over to the
line brasso around first
headed for second strong throw and he is
out at second base rosso
signals to the dugout to watch the video
and we've got a possible review
but guriel with a strong throw
panic had to make an acrobatic tag
because he had his back to the base
runner
great tag by joe panick and the rays are
not going to challenge
brandon lau comes up with an ops over a
thousand against lefties this season
trying to get him in a stretch early
swinging early into right field that's a
base hit from lao
up with the ball hernandez the throw is
cut
and the raise aggressively at first and
third
with one out emanuel margot ground ball
base hit right field
and the rays have a run a rosarina will
score loud holds second
and tampa bay has come out swinging he
has been the man on the spot
last night he comes through with a
two-run home run today early in the game
an rbi single look at the second coming
up one nothing raised
first here's an eno to left
guriel back he's run into one gone
two-run shot
mike zunino on an 0-2 pitch ray's heroes
have been manuel margot
and mike zunino manuel margot with two
on and
two out
bobbled the shet fires low and
everybody is safe in his approach he was
a little uncomfortable
gave himself you know a somewhat
difficult hop and then just makes
really a careless throw a census throw
here's hunter renfrow with the bases
loaded two out
drives it left field in the corner
guerrielle
gone slam
and tampa bay has kicked this thing
wide open this is a different tampa bay
team they're hitting home runs
they're doing what they they grind
they're grinding out at best they're
taking advantage of mistakes and
seven nothing early and ryu is done
the bottom of the third here in st
petersburg it's the raise seven toronto
one
and ray's have one on with one out and
randy rose arena coming up
that's fair ball and it sneaks down the
line off the bat of a rosarena
run around third coming home and the
rays are going to add a run
and it's 8-1 now how about the series
that
and the day that randy arose arena is
having right now to raise
an 8-1 lead trying to advance to the
division series
nate pearson the top prospect in the
jay's organization
swinging a miss and he strikes out
margot with 98.
hunter renfro stands in two pitch a
swing and a miss struck him out with a
slider two down
now the one-two pitch on its way
swinging a miss he struck out the side
here in the fourth we go to the fifth
eight one raise the class now we'll face
danny jansen the guy who homer off him
last time
oh my goodness my goodness jason again
his second that one missed the catwalk
but it's still impressive and it's 8-2
and jansen has
homered twice for the blue jays to the
sixth inning
eight-two raise oscar hernandez guerrero
at second
[Applause]
97 at the knees and that expression from
hernandez
says it all all right with two out
runner at second guerrero here's travis
shaw it's now the pitch swing gonna miss
he struck him out
98 with a fastball he strikes out three
in a row and has eight k's for the game
this young blue jay team has gotten
farther than anybody expected
but they're down to their last three
outs and here is panic and out away
on the ground this will do it and the
rays win it
they advance to the division series
they sweep the toronto blue jays